sens donc nous attend Edouard Ferrand
pour le Front national nous évoquons
justement la situation de ce parti il y
a quelques minutes et puis sur Twitter
d'ailleurs un téléspectateur réagissait
en se disant entre gauche et droite et
derrière le FN qui rigole bonsoir
Edouard Ferrand est-ce la situation ce
soir pour vous à Sens vous qui arrivez
deuxième derrière
oui c'est une c'est une belle victoire
ce soir à sens c'est la victoire des
patriotes je triple mes voies par
rapport à 2008 symbole j'arrive en
seconde position mais même si le PS est
éliminé pour le second tour il n'empêche
que l'UMP et le PS et la même phase
d'une même pièce et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un vrai
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine avec
tous les patriotes de gauche les
patriotes de droite qui ont envie de
d'une alternative à cette déconfiture
aujourd'hui de du personnel politique on
l'a vu avec l'Europe ultralibérale les
Français aujourd'hui sont vraiment dans
de grandes difficultés et je pense que
le message sur le plan national qui a
été lancé c'est le Front national arrive
et bien il faut s'y préparer
dans des villes où vous ne parvenez pas
à franchir cette fameuse barre des 10%,
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire et on
pense notamment à Auxerre ou votre
candidat Julien Guibert frôle les 10%
mais il est à 9 et quelques
quel message là aurez-vous dans ces
villes là
et bien d'abord sur Avallon nous avons
des élus sur Joigny nous sommes présents
second tour sur sens également sur
Auxerre effectivement il y avait un duel
annoncé c'était celui du PS et de l'UMP
mais aucune voix à l'UMP je crois
qu'aujourd'hui l'UMP montre que
finalement c'est la même politique c'est
cette politique aujourd'hui qui est
désastreuse qui a paupérisé la France et
donc nous ferons aucun appel à l'UMP
c'est sûr